[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei für den
Sport ein schön guten abag von mir und
das sind die Nachrichtenthemen von heute
AFD unter Druck die Partei wei die
Vorwürfe nach Treffen mit rechtsextremen
zurück währenddessen fordern 1 Million
Menschen Björn höcke Grundrecht zu
entziehen klarer Sieg für Donald Trump
in Iowa gewinnt er die Vorwahl der
Republikaner und bleibt Favorit im
Rennen um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur und
gefährliches Winterwetter tief gertrut
bringt Morgen viel Schnee und Glatteis
in die Mitte und den Süden
Deutschlands die Enthüllungen über ein
Geheimtreffen von AFD Politikern mit
führenden Rechtsextremisten Hallen nach
der Bundestag wird übermorgen darüber
debattieren und afdchefin Weidel trennte
sich von Ihrem persönlichen Referenten
der teilgenommen hatte zugleich empörte
sich Weidel über die Berichterstattung
der Medien und die Arbeit der
Journalisten von Korrektiv ausberlin
Christiane
hübscher alle Behauptungen sein unwahr
so geht Ali Weidel in die Offensive und
nennt die Korrektiv Recherchen einen der
größten Medien und politskandale der
Bundesrepublik es habe sich nicht um ein
Geheimtreffen gehandelt sondern um eine
private
Zusammenkunft die von diesen
korrektivaktivisten mit
Geheimdienstmethoden unter Missachtung
von Persönlichkeitsrechten
infiltriert und ausgespätt worden war um
eine
Verschwörungstheorie gleich zu
Jahresbeginn zu konstruieren warum sie
sich dennoch gestern Abend von Ihrem
Berater trennte der an besagtem Treffen
in podam teilgenommen hat diesen
Widerspruch löst Weidel heute nicht auf
bestätigt aber einen Zusammenhang kchef
Tino kropalla reagiert scharf auf die
Frage ob auch er bei den Treffen mit
Neonazis dabei war beruft sich auf die
Versammlungsfreiheit und von daher geht
sie wo ich mich privat mit wem auch
immer treffe ich sag es so deutlich
einen feuchten kehicht an die
Demonstrationen gegen die in Teilen
rechtsextreme Partei gehen weiter Sowi
hier in Leipzig warnende Stimmen kommen
von Politik bis Wirtschaft
ich will kein Land ind dem es drauf
ankommt wo deine Großeltern geboren sind
ob du in diesem Land willkommen bist
oder nicht das können wir uns
gesellschaftlich nicht leisten es reicht
auch nicht sich dann von dem bürroleiter
zu trennen wie Frau Weidel es macht
nachdem od ich habe davon ja nichts
gewusst Herr krupaller hat auch
Erinnerungslücken und weiß aber dabei
war es ist erkennbar die Indizien mehren
sich auch die Debatte über ein AFD
Verbot wird weitergeführt doch für ein
solches Verfahren scheint es bisher
keine Mehrheit zu geben lieber politisch
bekämpfen hört man heute wieder öfter in
Berlin die Enthüllung des Treffens hat
einiges in Gang gesetzt nicht nur die
Demos gegen Rechts und die Debatte um
ein AFD Verbotsverfahren auch eine
Kampagne gegen Björn höcke bekommt viel
Unterstützung über eine Million Menschen
haben online eine Petition
unterschrieben die den Thüringer AFD
Chef stoppen soll mit Hilfe des
Grundgesetzes das ermöglicht es
Verfassungsfeinden einzelne Grundrechte
zu entziehen Christoph
desterell sich Rechtsextremisten
entgegenstellen tausende taten das am
Wochenende gingen etwa in sabrücken
Potzdam oder Berlin auf die Straße sich
einem Rechtsextremisten entgegenstellen
den Weg geht derzeit eine Online
Petition Motto unterschreiben und so
höcke stoppen kurz nach Mittag wurde die
1 Million Marke geknackt warum gezielt
den Thüringer AFD Vorsitzenden angehen
die Organisation Camp schreibt dazu
höcke hzt gegen die im Grundgesetz
verankerte freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung die Erinnerungskultur in
Bezug auf den Holocaust und Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund die Petition setzt
auf das Grundgesetz Artikel 18 demnach
können einer einzelnen Person einzelne
Grundrechte entzogen werden Begründung
wer etwa Presse oder
Versammlungsfreiheit zum Kampfe gegen
die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung missbraucht verwirkt diese
Grundrechte die Ver und ihr Ausmaß
werden durch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ausgesprochen
mit vielleicht weitreichenden Folgen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht könnte Björn
höcke nicht nur einzelne Grundrechte
entziehen sondern auch anordnen dass er
zumindest zeitweise nicht mehr bei
Wahlen antreten darf vier Verfahren über
Artikel 18 gab es bislang wie etwa 1974
beim früheren Herausgeber der deutschen
Nationalzeitung Gerhard frei verliefen
alle ins Lehre aber im Gegensatz zu
früheren Fällen sehen Juristen bei einem
Verfahren zur Grundrecht Verwirkung
gegen Björn höcke höhere Erfolgschancen
denn er ist zweifelsohne einflussreich
und bekannt und seine Äußerung könnten
vom bundsverfassungsgericht als Angriff
auf die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung gewertet werden höcke den
der Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch einstuft wertet die
Petition als Angriff auf seine
politische Arbeit das Ziel ist der
oppositionelle als un bzw nicht menensch
dem logischerweise auch keine
Grundrechte mehr zustehen der
Rechtsstaat geht ein neuer
ideologiestaat droht gut für höcke
schlecht für die Petition alle früheren
Verfahren nach Artikel 18 dauerten
jeweils über 4er
Jahre in die USA wird Donald Trump im
November noch einmal zum Präsidenten
gewählt die kandidatenvorwahl der
Republikaner im US-Bundesstaat Iowa hat
der 77jährige auf jeden Fall klar
gewonnen 51% der Stimmen holte Trump bei
dieser ersten Abstimmung und ließ damit
seine Herausforderer weit hinter sich
Ron deantis Gouverneur von flouda kam
auf 21% und die frühere unbotschafterin
Nicki Haley erhielt 19% der Stimmen
ma wisen in Iowa das war die erste von
50 Abstimmungen der Republikaner über
ihren Kandidaten was sagt dieses
Ergebnis
aus also es zeigt dass Donald Trump
seine Partei fest im Griff hat es war
natürlich nur 110000
Wähler aber das Ergebnis ist das Beste
das hier ein republikanischer
Präsidentschaftskandidat hier in aowa
hatte und es beweist dass vielen egal
ist all diese Prozesse gegen Donald
Trump dass sie in seinem Hang zum
Autoritarismus sogar einen Vorteil sehen
weil ein starker Anführer ihnen ihre
Ängste nehmen kann wenn er nächste Woche
in new hampchire verlieren würde bei der
nächsten Vorwahl Nicki Haley
beispielsweise könnte ihn schlagen nur
dann bekäme dieses Image von unver
wundbarkeit noch ein paar Kratzer wenn
das nicht geschieht dann wird er einen
Durchmarsch machen innerhalb seiner
eigenen Partei das bedeutet nicht dass
er die Wahl im November dann auch
automatisch gewinnt denn schon jetzt
schürt ja Joe Biden der Amtsinhaber
Angst vor einem autoritären Donald Trump
im Weißen Haus und es gibt auch das
zeigen die Ergebnisse hier in aowa doch
auch eine Zahl von republikanischen
Wähler die den trumpismus insgesamt
ablehnen also es bleibt spannend in
diesem Wahljahr danke schön Elma
twiissen war das live aus dem
verschneiten dem in
Iowa im Nahen Osten wächst die Sorge
dass sich der Gazakrieg weiter in der
Region ausdehnen könnte Iran hat in der
Nacht Raketen auf Ziele in Syrien und im
Norden des Iraks abgefeuert ein Ziel
soll eine mutmaßliche Zentrale des
israelischen Geheimdienstes in der
irakischen Stadt Erbil gewesen sein bei
dem Angriff wurde mindestens vier
Menschen getötet außerdem Griff Iran
angebliche Stellungen der
Terrororganisation is in Syrien
an es ist die höchstgelegene Stadt
Europas daavo es in der Schweiz auch
Anfang dieses Jahres treffen sich dort
auf 1560 m Höhe traditionell viele
mächtige dieser Welt und wieder diktiert
der Krieg in der Ukraine einen wichtigen
Teil der Tagesordnung Ulf Röller ist
dort Präsident eilt von Termin zu Termin
Treffen mit NATO Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg die Ukraine braucht dringend
mehr Waffen warten auf selenski Treffen
unter ander mit Politik und Wirtschaft
der Ukraine geht das Geld aus selenski
hat die Sorge dass bei den vielen Krisen
die internationale Gemeinschaft die
Ukraine
vergisst der Krieg wird enden und
sammelt einen gerechten und stabilen
Frieden wir brauchen unsere Partner
jetzt und auch für den Wiederaufbau uns
und unser
Gesellschaft die Krisen und der Krieg
dieser Welt haben sich bis in die
Schweizer Berge durchgefressen 60
Regierungschefs in Davos auf der Suche
nach Lösungen Jake Sullivan könnte
helfen der nationale Sicherheitsberater
der USA aber der innenpolitische Streit
lehmt Amerika die Republikaner
blockieren die
ukrainehilfe mit einem
versprechen wir müssen in der L sein die
Waffen deruk zu liefern die sie braucht
damit sie sich verteidigen kann es muss
uns gelingen im Kongress überparteiliche
Mehrheiten
hinzubekommen Rededuell der Weltmächte
Chinas Nummer 2 Ministerpräsident lang
suchte keine Konfrontation sein Land
steht zwar eng an der Seite Russlands
aber peking will den Kontakt zum Westen
nicht abbrechen lassen wir müssen eine
bessere Zukunft schaffen dafür müssen
wir Brücken bauen und unsere Differenzen
en das geht nur
gemeinsam was das für den ukrainekrieg
heißt sagt Liang nicht mit keinem Wort
erwähnt er den Konflikt auch in der wos
bleibt die Welt
unübersichtlich
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann von der
FDP will das Familienrecht modernisieren
in Berlin stellte er seine Pläne vor
viele Kinder wüchsen heute in trennungs
oder regenbogenfilien auf das bisherige
Familienrecht hinke dahinterher sagt
Buschmann was sich etwa im Sorgerecht
und für Adoptionen ändern soll weiß
Dominik
tppker zwei lesbische Frauen mit einem
Kind die eine Frau ist die leibliche
Mutter wenn auch die andere das
Sorgerecht für das Kind bekommen will
muss sie es bisher adoptieren ein hoher
Aufwand doch das will der Justizminister
jetzt
ändern das Familienglück gehört bei
lesbischen Paaren genauso bei vielen
jedenfalls genauso zu einer Vorstellung
vom Glück wie bei heterosexuellen Paaren
und dass wir es diesen Menschen in der
Vergangenheit sehr schwer gemacht haben
einfach so behandelt zu werden vom Recht
wie andere verheiratete Paare auch finde
ich ist ein Handlungsauftrag und den
wollen wir jetzt erfüllen eine lesbische
Frau die ein Kind erwartet ist auch
künftig die Mutter dieses Kindes nach
den Plänen der Ampel soll bald auch die
Partnerin der Frau die Elternschaft
erhalten können auch ohne Adoption kann
sie künftig die zweite Mutter dieses
Kindes werden wir freuen uns wahnsinnig
dass die Politik sich endlich auf den
Weg begibt endlich Gleichberechtigung
für Regenbogenfamilien und insbesondere
für zwei mütterfamilien zu schaffen das
ist aus unserer Sicht lange überfällig
mit der Reform will die Ampel außerdem
leiblichen Vätern die Anerkennung ihrer
Vaterschaft erleichtern und Kinder
sollen wissen dürfen wer ihr leiblicher
Vater ist wobei das Ergebnis keine
Auswirkungen haben soll auf die
rechtliche Vaterschaft aus den
Reformplänen soll noch in diesem Jahr
ein Gesetz werden werden im Sommer soll
es dann den Bundestag
passieren die Zahl der Organspenden in
Deutschland ist vergangenes Jahr
gestiegen nach einem starken Rückgang im
Jahr
2022 nach Angaben der Deutschen Stiftung
Organtransplantation spendeten
965 Menschen nach ihrem Tod ein oder
mehrere Organe das waren 96 mehr als im
Vorjahr nach wie vor bestehe ein
erheblicher Mangel an Spendeorganen sagt
die Stiftung in Deutschland warten knapp
8400 Menschen auf eine
Organtransplantation Tag und Nacht haben
die Menschen in den Hochwassergebieten
in den vergangenen Wochen gegen die
Fluten gekämpft niedersachsen will jetzt
zusätzlich 110 Millionen Euro
bereitstellen mit dem Nachtragshaushalt
sollen unter anderem Privathaushalte und
Firmen unterstützt werden die Schäden
wegen des Hochwassers haben der größte
Teil soll in die Hochwasser bekämp
fließen z.B in mobile Schutzsysteme um
für mögliche neue Fluten besser
vorbereitet zu
sein es braut sich ein ziemlich
unangenehmes und gefährliches
Winterwetter über dem Süden und
Südwesten Deutschlands zusammen das Tief
Gertrud bringt sehr viel Schnee und
tückischen Eisregen der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt vor extremer Glätte
auf Straßen und Wegen Bäume könnten
unter Schneelasten zusammenbrechen
Markus
wolsffer heute Mittag kurz vor 13 Uhr
Millionen Handys warnen extreme Gefahr
Unwetter Schneefälle klatteis die
lufthansar muss deshalb großflächig
Flüge streichen vor allem an ihren
Drehkreuzen Frankfurt und München wir
versuchen die Passagiere umzubuchen so
gut das geht aber das wird Auswirkung
haben das Wetter morgen und übermorgen
erst am Freitag rechnen wir wieder mit
Normalisierung bei
7800000 Quadrat Betriebsfläche viel
Arbeit für den Winterdienst am
Frankfurter Flughafen auf das Schlimmste
bereiten sich auch viele
straßenmeistereinen vor wie hier in
Wiesbaden mit bis zu 30 cm Schnee
rechnen Sie hier um 3 Uhr in der Nacht
beginnt die Schicht klar ist die Männer
und Frauen können nie überall
gleichzeitig sein wir räumen erstmal
alle wichtigen Hauptverkehrsadern und
alle Busstrecken und was auch wichtig
ist natürlich alle Zufahrten zu
Krankenhäusern auch die Bahn rechnet
wegen des Unwetters mit bundesweiten
Auswirkungen im regional und Fernverkehr
wer seine für morgen geplante Reise
verschieben muss kann sein Ticket auch
später nutzen die z ung ist
aufgehoben Katja hornefer aus unserer
Wetter Raktion weiß mehr guten Abend
Katja was genau kommt da auf uns zu das
geht in der zweiten Nachthälfte los und
zwar von Südwesten da kommt erstmal
Schnee an im Schwarzwald und dann wird
da ganz schnell gefährlicher
Glatteisregen draus und dieser
Glatteisregen erreicht etwa bis morgen
früh zum Berufsverkehr das Saarland das
südliche Rheinland-Pfalz und das
nördliche Baden-Württemberg hier auf
dieser Grafik sehen wir was wir morgen
genau erwarten denn nördlich von diesem
Glatteisregen fällt auch kräftiger
Schnee ungefähr von der Eifel bis zum
Thüringerwald erwarten wir schon morgen
10 bis 20 dann bis Donnerstag vielleicht
sogar bis zu 40 cm Neuschnee m das
betrifft viele Menschen wie geht's dann
weiter am Donnerstag wird diese Front
rückläufig wie wir das nennen das heißt
sie ist ja von Süden herangezogen jetzt
aber zieht sie nach Süden wieder raus
dann ist aber die große Gefahr vorbei
das heißt der Regen geht dann wieder in
Schnee über und verlässt uns langsam
südostwärts also wer kann der sollte in
den Risikogebieten zu Hause bleiben
vielen Dank Katja mehr von dir nachher
und wer sich kurzfristig über Schnee und
Glätte informieren will mit unserer ZDF
heute App halten wir Sie auf dem
Laufenden wo es wie gerade aussieht und
was es zu beachten gbt
idfix den kennen die meisten als
cleveren Hund aus den Asterix und Obelix
Comics für einen deutschfanzösischen
Weltraum Rover soll der Name nun
Programm sein der idfix auf vier Rädern
wurde heute vom deutschen Luft und
Raumfahrtzentrum erstmal nach Japan
geschickt von dort soll er dann
2026 zum Marsmond fobos starten und dort
ein bisschen
rumschnüffeln sprich die Oberfläche
erkunden und hier auf der Erde muss das
deutsche Handballteam in einer guten
Stunde gegen die Franzosen ran Norbert
letztes Vorrundenspiel der EM ja
spannend spannt das dh bteam das hat ja
nach zwei Siegen die Hauptrunde schon
erreicht der Rekordweltmeister aber noch
nicht nur ein Sieg und ein Unentschieden
egal verlieren verboten heißt es für
beide heute Abend denn die Punkte aus
diesem Spiel die werden in die
Hauptrunde
mitgenommen auf welchem Level das
dhbteam um Torhüter Andreas Wolf aktuell
wirklich steht wird sich gegen die
Franzosen heute abend zeigen im
vergangenen Jahr noch im WM
Viertelfinale gegen Frankreich
ausgeschieden soll es bei der Heim em
auch dank der Euphorie und des
lautstarken Publikums besser laufen
einfach wird es aber nicht wir müssen
einer unseren besten Spiele der letzten
Jahre bringen um die franzosischen
schlagen damit das deutsche
handballwintermärchen auch in der
Hauptrunde
weitergeht der deutsche Fußball trauert
um Kai Bernstein den Präsidenten von
Herter BSC der 43-Jährige war einst
Vorsänger der Berliner Fans in der
Ostkurve wurde dann im Sommer 2022
überraschend zum Präsidenten gewählt
Herter steckte da bereits in einer
tiefen Krise Bernstein konnte trotz
großem Engagement Talfahrt und Abstieg
des Vereins nicht
aufhalten zu den Australian Open da ist
Angeli kber in der ersten Runde
ausgeschieden Olympiasieger Alexander
Zeref dagegen mit einem hartkämpften
Auftaktsieg gegen Dominik
Köpfer ZF Spiel gelegentlich zu
inkonsequent seine Vorhand ungewohnt
schwach doch das weiß er selbst ich habe
jetzt nicht mein bestnis gespielt aber
ich meine wann ma ich das schon bei der
ersten Runde auf seinen Aufschlag aber
kann er sich verlassen bis zu 218 km pro
Stunde schnell 19 Asse der
Weltranglisten sech ist auch in mäßiger
Form zu stark für Köpfer die Nummer
62 nach gut D Stunden siegt Alexander S
mit 4:6 6:3 7 Z6 und
6 und trifft nun auf den slowakischen
Qualifikanten
klein morgen bestreiten Laura Siegemund
und Tamara korpat ihr zweites Spiel
vielen Dank was das Wetter außer
glettete noch für uns parat hält dazu
gleich noch mal Katja horneffer das
heute journal mit dunia Hayali um :4 Uhr
wir sagen danke und tschüss bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
noch
guten Abend Mitternacht geht's los da
zieht von Südwesten zunächst Schnee auf
und dann auch gefährlicher Glatteisregen
dieser Glatteisregen erreicht bis morgen
früh ungefähr das Saarland das südliche
rheinlandpfals und das nördliche
baden-würtenemberg bis mittags zieht der
Glatteisregen ein bisschen weiter nach
Norden und dann gibt's auch kräftige
Schneefälle ungefähr zwischen der Eifel
und dem Thüringerwald 10 bis 20 bis
Donnerstag sogar bis zu 40 cm Neuschnee
bis zum Abend bleibt's gefährlich glatt
auf unseren Straßen zwischen dem
Saarland und dem nördlichen Bayern das
Problem ist dass es am Boden so eiskalt
ist heute Nacht sinken die Temperaturen
auf -1 bis -10° an der Küste gibt's auch
noch einige Schneeschauer morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen um den
Gefrierpunkt im Südwesten macht sich die
mildere Luft bemerkbar da klettern die
Werte am Nachmittag bis 11° von diesem
sehr unschönen Wetter mit Schnee und
Eisregen bekommen sie morgen zwischen
der Weser und der oder nichts mit da
sehen sie sogar mal die Sonne und an den
Küsten gibt's einige Schneeschauer am
Donnerstag ziehen Schnee und
Glatteisregen südwärts danach wird es
deutlich ruhiger guten Abend